around 800 asphalt Cowboys follow the
call of the first Mustang Club of
Germany and brought their automotive
wild horses to the 33rd international
Mustang meeting in Cologne hear the
distinctive burbling sound of v8 engines
is heard everywhere as fans come to mark
the 50th anniversary of Ford's pony car
visitors can admire the Mustangs of
today and yesteryear spins ight Oh form
says he's been chairman of the first
Mustang Club of Germany for some 25
years originally the club was dedicated
to first generation Mustangs built
between 1964 1973 but now it organizes
the meeting for Mustangs of all vintages
form says they never wanted to be just a
small group of first generation fans so
they've been able to present 50 years of
Mustangs here in Cologne on 50 shoppable
Stegman difficulty of car meets like
this always draw unusual cars and their
owners like this Mustang decked out in
the colors of the Chicago Bears football
team and its owner who's painted his
nails to match
this Highway Patrol show car ensures law
and order prevail at the meet and this
Mustang from Holland is a replica of a
race car with an interesting history
this is actually it's a replica of a
race car that was owned by Tim Allen the
actor from home improvement a TV series
in the mid 90s he actually financed the
racing team of steve saleen and because
he put so much money in they offered him
a racing seat on the team so actually
the three cars that they raised in the
SSC a pro series one of them was
occasionally driven by Tim Allen himself
and this car is actually a replica of
the car how his car used to look back in
the 90s the mere sight of a dragster
like this is enough to set a Mustang
fans heart racing but it wasn't love at
first sight for all the owners here off
has never imagined he'd fall for this
green machine
in the new study says he stumbled across
his green frog and got in started it up
and then the fever hit it wouldn't of
all this fee by inch Donna if that
Mustang fever ever turns into a raging
fire this car couldn't help him cool
down movie buffs will recognize this
replica of Eleanor the 1967 fastback
Mustang Nicolas Cage steals and gone in
60 seconds Ford marked the Mustangs 50th
anniversary by showing off its 2015
edition of the car for the first time in
Europe at the meeting in Cologne
everyone wanted to get a shot of the new
model
you have to dig it Ford's your buyer
says as executive director for global
programs he had a chance to collaborate
on the new Mustang in the US he says
they had very high aims the vehicle had
to drive well look smart and thrilled
people but ford also wanted the Mustang
to remain an affordable sports car for
an extremely shafaq Scott bug black Ford
hasn't set a price for the new Mustang
in Europe but it's known it will offer a
choice of two engines there's the 2.3
liter four-cylinder EcoBoost which in
spite of its 227 kilowatts is
fuel-efficient those wanting a classic
American motor can opt for the five
liter v8 which generates 313 kilowatts
but fans will have to wait a bit longer
before it hits the streets
you